- [Instructor] What I'd
like to do in this video
is talk about the major
schools of Buddhism
as it is practiced today.
And it can be broadly divided
into Theravada Buddhism,
which means school of the elder monks,
and Mahayana Buddhism,
which means great vehicle.
Maha for great.
So first on the commonalities.
Now both of these schools
of Buddhist thought
or Buddhist tradition
believe in this notion of the
cycle of birth and rebirth
from one life or one reality to the next,
that we call samsara which is also shared
with the core of Hindu philosophy.
And this idea that your
goal should be to realize
that all is thought,
to escape from the dukkha and
eventually obtain nirvana.
Now the difference between
the two schools of thought,
in Theravada buddhism, it is much closer
to some of the original
practices or teachings
that we see with
Siddhartha Gautama Buddha.
It is a very personal journey
that is all about the
individual though meditation,
perhaps with some help from some teacher
recognizing the non-self,
recognizing that we are all one,
and eventually,
either in this life or in future lives,
achieving nirvana.
Now Mahayana Buddhism actually encompasses
a very large set of various practices
but the general idea is
that you might have help
as you try to achieve nirvana.
Someone who achieves nirvana
is known as an arhat,
so you could Therevada Buddhism as,
hey try to go on this personal
journey to become an arhat,
to achieve nirvana.
But in Mahayana Buddhism,
the pursuit is not
necessarily to get to nirvana
as quickly as possible.
It's to get close to nirvana
but then to help others
try to achieve that same state
So the real goal is to be
a bodhisattva, bodhisattva.
Now the word bodhisattva
is used in both traditions.
In Theravada Buddhism,
it refers to someone
who is trying to become an arhat.
Someone who is on the
path to achieving nirvana.
In Mahayana Buddhism,
it is someone who has
almost achieved nirvana
but holds that off in order to help
the rest of the sentient reality.
The rest of sentient beings
eventually achieve nirvana
and if you aren't one of the bodhisattvas,
you have that help not
only from bodhisattvas
but there's a fairly large grouping
of celestial beings
that are there to help.
That are there to help
focus your meditation
and your energy.
And what you see here is a
depiction that's not atypical
from a Mahayana Buddhist shrine.
In the middle here, you
have Amitabha Buddha
and a significant chunk of
Mahayana Buddhists believe
in Amitabha Buddha and you could view him
as someone who's revered or
is almost a deity-like figure.
And this idea that by visualizing,
by focusing, by invoking
Amitabha Buddha, that you can
get to his pure land of bliss
known as Sukhavati.
And so it's this idea of
almost a kind of salvation.
That by focusing on Amitabha,
you get to this pure land of bliss
which is a place where it
is easier to achieve nirvana
from and you can almost view
it as something of a heaven.
Now what's interesting is
Amitabha Buddha isn't exactly
the same figure as
Siddhartha Gautama Buddha.
in some traditions,
Siddhartha Gautama Buddha
is a projection of Amitabha
into our reality.
And in some Mahayana belief systems
there are multiple realities,
each with their own Buddha
and you can be born and reborn
into these different
realities and the pure land,
the pure land of bliss,
the Sukhavati is where
you might want to go
if you are following,
if you are practicing this
belief in Amitabha Buddha.
So at a very high level,
Theravada buddhism is all
about this personal journey.
Trying to follow the practice
of Siddhartha Gautama Buddha
through meditation, through recognizing
the four noble truths, by
following the middle way,
getting eventually in this life
and in future lives to nirvana,
becoming an arhat.
Mahayana buddhism has
a more complex pantheon
of celestial beings and deities
and can be diverse form one
part of the world to another.
Eventually the goal is
for all sentient beings
to achieve nirvana.
But your individual goal
can be better described
as delaying nirvana, become a bodhisattva,
and assisting all other sentient beings
in achieving that nirvana.
These are actually the
attendant bodhisattvas
on the left and the
right of Amitabha Buddha.
But you don't have just the
help of the bodhisattvas,
there's also celestial beings,
things that you can focus on,
things that you can invoke
to eventually help you
get you to that nirvana.
Now in order to see where it is practiced,
we have this map right over here.
First of all, most of
buddhism is practiced
in the far east of asia or southeast asia.
And you see the various
schools of buddhism.
So in red here, you have the Therevada,
the school of the elder monks.
In yellow here, you have
Mahayana, the great vehicle.
And in orange, you have Vajrayana.
A significant chunk of Vajrayana Buddhists
are often referred to as Tibetan Buddhists
and they're sometimes
grouped with the Mahayana,
it's closer to Mahayana.
There's this notion of boddhisatvas.
There are celestial beings.
There are more rituals.
Now in terms of population,
the country with the largest
Buddhist population is China,
roughly 250 million Buddhists
of the 500 million Buddhists
that there are in the world.
But despite the fact that
there are so many Buddhists
in China, it is still only 18%
of the entire Chinese population.
In places like Burma and Thailand,
you have a much higher
percentage of the population
that is actually Buddhist
and these regions of southeast asia,
most of the population is Buddhist.
Now one other really
interesting thing about this map
is we talk about buddhism
starting in northeast India,
in southern Nepal.
That's where Siddhartha
Gautama Buddha lived.
That's where he spread his teachings.
And not only is that where it originated,
you have Ashoka who really
catalyzed the spread of buddhism
and once again that was out of India.
But when you look at this demographic map
of where you have significant
Buddhist groupings,
you don't see a lot in India.
You see a lot in Sri Lanka.
And that's actually where
the Theravada tradition
comes primarily from.
And there's a couple of
interesting explanations
as to why you don't see it in India.
One possible explanation is
that it was so close to many
versions on Hindu practices
and we talk about Hinduism
being this very diverse
and open religion.
And it really just got
reabsorbed, reassimilated
as part of the diverse Hindu tradition.
In fact, many Hindus view Buddha
as another incarnation of Vishnu.